welcome back to new rock stars I'm Eric
Voss here with M Marvel kamicon herself
Iman volani to talk about the Marvels
the MCU X-Men and whether Kevin feige
has confiscated your MCU notebook yet
welcome back to the channel Aman ah
never gets old that intro and no he
hasn't confiscated The Notebook you
carry it with you everywhere I love that
you know there's like like literally
three pages left I'm I'm writing so
small because I don't my the worst thing
is like starting a new notebook I think
this is volume two maybe um but it's
terrifying you just I I like it when it
rips I like it when it gets old and I
got to fix it with stickers and oh you
fix it with stickers that's brilliant we
got we got like Iron Man holding
everything together but it's like really
just falling apart yeah that's amazing
um I gotta say our interview back in
July 2022 is one of my all-time favorite
new rock star videos we've ever made and
so me and my theories as you indicated
what happened did not come to pass
but we said we would do a part two after
the Marvels came out and here we are
thank you so much for coming back to do
this thank you for having me I was so
excited when I saw your name on the list
of all my like interviews it's just
refreshing and and this is all the last
one of the day so okay perfect cherry on
top all right awesome thank you to boxu
for sponsoring this video more on their
tasty offerings later uh so I got to
congratulate you in every review and
reaction I have seen everyone is now
seeing the light of how you the way that
you were playing Kamala Khan has just
been one of the godsend in the MCU in
recent years and I think you know this
is a Time Iman that critics would
probably be reluctant to share praise
but no one can deny it you've like also
been on the fan side of everything I
think you understand how much pressure
there is to deliver and I'm just floored
at how well you're pulling it off and I
just want to thank you for bringing
Kamala Khan home for so many Marvel fans
thank you that was I'm like trembling a
little bit um that that's very sweet
it's it is a lot of pressure only when I
think about it but honestly i' I've
learned that if if I'm like having
fun it'll show and and I think people
will have fun watching fun I think
honestly fun is like the key word here
and I've been using it so much during
all the fres but the movie is genuinely
fun and I think people will be surprised
at how much fun they're actually having
I think sometimes you forget that movies
are meant to be a good time you know a
couple Fun hours of escapism why not
100% and like I think we this movie
reminds audiences I think we need to do
a better job reminding audiences that it
is okay to have fun and to lose yourself
in the moment when you're watching these
movies and I think you embody that so
well and specifically let's start at the
end of The Movie Spoiler warning to
anyone who's Nots yet why would you
click on this video but more the warning
final scene Kamala Khan recruits Kate
Bishop to it seems like a future lineup
maybe the Young Avengers and I think
this was so perfect because you are
clearly reenacting Samuel Jackson's uh
Iron Man post credit scene and I would
say this is just me but I think not
since Robert dowy Jr have we seen an
actor just relax and have fun in the
role because often when you watch MCU
movies the actor despite their talent
seems a little bit terrified but it
seems like you Iman get that this is a
rock concert you you do have to focus up
and get serious sometimes but for the
rest enjoy the ride is that how it feels
everyone's yeah everyone's letting me
have a good time I think the worst thing
you could do to someone is like put a
damper on their excitement and I'm just
so everything's so cool you know we we
shot on on the volume for a lot of it so
the tech just leveled up I'm working
with Sam Jackson like shooting Young
Avengers getting the honors to repeat
Sam's lines it's cool like objectively
cool why can't I be excited and
obviously like they're like a lot of the
times they don't even let me see um some
of the stuff that we're doing in
rehearsal they're just like whatever
your reaction is going to be just just
channel that like for um the jump points
like when we're in the spaceship so all
that the jump points that we're seeing
it was real like we we it was the volume
and they had animated the real thing and
they didn't let me watch it and then we
we shot it and I'm like sitting on this
like already cool Spaceship set and then
they start playing the jump point and
literally you feel like you are in space
it is you were in the MCU space it was
just cool on like so many levels and I
think the reaction that's in the film is
like one of the first takes that we did
it's just it never gets old yeah it it
seems very authentic and and you say in
another interview that originally the
scene with Kate Bishop was scripted to
have Kamala meeting someone else was it
the other person the daughter that
Kamala hints at or someone else someone
else's plural there was a few people um
but I you know what I like this version
better because I want to see Camala
collect her Infinity Stones I want her I
like my favorite part in Avengers like
the first film is Nick Fury going to
Steve Rogers and black widow going to
Hulk and everyone like just Gathering
the group together and then the band's
all on the Hella carrier and they're
meeting for the first time and they're
fighting and they're like learning how
to work together I want to see that all
happen so I think it wouldn't make sense
if and and they knew that too when they
wrote I think it was just like a
placeholder scene anyway um that if the
all the Young Avengers were already
together like it it wouldn't make sense
and I think you're missing out on such
like a fun piece of content that we
could have had you know yeah I mean that
assembly is just core to all this right
like it's almost like a stretch out
version of the get the gang together I'm
in you know like you need to take your
time with that I agree no exactly
exactly milk it as long as you can until
we're all like 30 so I'm curious just as
you know obviously you're a fan of the
Young Avengers Comics uh what kind of
MCU conflict or crisis would you want to
see the Young Avengers tackle I'm gonna
go back to Champ I actually don't read
Young Avengers I read Champions more
okay um thank you for being honest you
would say that to any other MCU actor
they'd be like yes I read all of those
Comics my assistant hased me to people
who haven't read the comics I say I read
everything they don't know any better
yeah um okay so the Champions yeah
Champions is maybe a better group than
Young Avengers that might be
controversal you I I thought it was a
hot take but it's not I I think most
people their chemistry is so much better
they feel like actual teenagers the way
like she interacts with with Sam
Alexander and Miles Morales like it's my
favorite Trio and I want it to happen so
badly um but I think in one of the
recent uh Champions runs it's called
outlawed and Camala like dies almost or
something and a big explosion happens
and they create this thing called
kamala's law and dum dum Dugan's like
after her and after all these like kid
superheroes it's so bizarre but um I I I
like the idea of that of like oh maybe
children should not be superheroes and
maybe they shouldn't be fighting but
they do bring a whole different
perspective I think one of the first
like that the Champions have been
fighting like social justice issues for
for so long and and they're so right on
so many levels and they see things in a
way adults kind of don't um so obviously
I'm I'm for it but I think that would be
a fun thing to play with because there's
so many young people that are being
introduced in the MCU and in the comics
and yeah it would be it would be fun I
don't think they'll get dumb Dum Dugan
but yeah we can hope they'd have to jump
through a couple Hoops to figure that
one out but um he's a variant yeah he's
a variant from he's he's a squirrel the
whole time since Civil War okay so
little detail I spotted I don't know if
it was just like an animator detail
Camala in her notebook early in the
movie writes that she hates spiders you
mentioned miles BR was that intentional
is that a possible nod to a Meetup all
right
so loud and clear they just I mean they
they you know they they put Easter eggs
for such random things whatever they can
come up with and if no one Flags it it's
in the
film just to drive people like me crazy
I'm sure I oh yeah I'm sure all right uh
we got to talk about X-Men you were
technically the MC's first declared
mutant you're baptized with Ron W's
X-Men um so let's talk about beast in
this movie we put our spoiler morning at
the top um you said you didn't know what
this Cameo was gonna be until you saw C
of the movie uh but can I ask you as a
you know as just a fan of it might not
know fully what Marvel's plan is what
X-Men Universe do you think they are in
here like what Universe does this take
place in the the first three films I
guess yeah right like Kelsey Grammar
that only makes sense um I mean they did
have is it 838 they did have like old
Charles Xavier in that one but he didn't
have his like yellow wheelchair in the
films right so it could be a different
universe but also maybe he just got the
wheelchair later I don't know uh any
X-Men universe is f that's not true I
was going to say any X-Men universe is
fine with me but I still refuse to watch
dark Phoenix
um hey you know who knows it can all be
Canon Now Kevin feige has said it was
who doesn't matter who directed it it
could all end up being in the in the
Melting Pot and if Kevin fuggy says it
is so Kelsey Grammar as the beast is
just such a specific pull like they
could have pulled I know Patrick seart
back or Mars Den back in but they're
like no no no we want you to think about
and they were flexing on us with that CG
I was very impressed when I saw the
little teeth uhhuh the yeah um which I
it feels like they use some of the
technology that they use on Ruffalo for
Hulk you know but they they did it
specifically to get like a comic
accurate Beast you know just out of
curiosity Beast mentioned Charles Xavier
who do you think would be Charles in
this reality would be steuart or makoy
Stuart seems to make more sense steuart
I think steuart makes sense yeah given
BEAST's age and he's already in beasty
mode you know I I think Stuart so
hopefully Ian McKellen's somewhere in
there too right right then tberry pops
up I think it' be jump scare if we get
Anna pacin too but jump scare now we got
to talk about this Marvel comic you're
currently writing yourself M Marvel the
new Mutant as a mutant M Marvel is now
canonically a mutant in the pages of the
comics now how important is it for you
to redefine Kamala Khan this way and
what has this process been like for you
I genuinely thought they were going to
humor me with like a cute little one
shot I didn't expect they they were like
they kept throwing around oh she's dying
and she's coming back as a mutant and
that's the storyline you're going to be
given I was like what are you talking
about like you know I've never written
anything ever except like English essays
they were like yeah it's fine just like
the stories matter and I was like okay
um and then I like had my first pitch
and and I I had all these ideas I was
like I'm gonna AG Cala up she's going to
college like that's great we're not
doing that she's 16 forever but no it's
been amazing and also like the fact that
it matters so much I've seen so much
discourse on online and I know it's like
people have their opinions but I love to
see it because I haven't I didn't
realize that she's an important enough
character for people to care so much
about a change like this you know it to
see the community come together and
collectively agree on something it's
it's just even if it's like a negative
thing but it's still wonderful to see
them coming together and I I missed that
I I I love like you know 2019 the the
fandom was just amazing like people were
going crazy over every single detail
that was posted by the endgame directors
or anything and just any taste of that
and anything to do with me like the fact
that people are talking about my comic
as you know as if it's such a big deal
is honestly such an honor and and I love
seeing all the discourse it's amazing I
have to compliment you on your attitude
about this Iman because if you had asked
me about this I'd be like the internet
is a hell hole so yeah but it doesn't
matter like these are superhero hero
they're not real just
like
yeah yeah 100% I I get it I people are
very possessive and protective over
these characters but it all comes out of
a place of love and passion and and the
reason I think like this is because if I
wasn't in the position that I'm in I
would also probably be on those forums
saying like Angry typing and and just
like you know saying the worst things
but so so I get it and I and I realized
you know the internet doesn't have all
the information they don't know where
they're going they don't know the future
um so I I'll just enjoy it while I can
um which is great and and hopefully yeah
and honestly like I have to say thank
you to you like I don't think I got to
properly say this last time but
seriously you you have like fueled the
passion of of so many fans myself
included you know so and you're like so
constructive with with the with your
content and and you keep everything
positive positive so it's just it's it's
very refreshing like you can you can
tell a lot by fan with which Youtuber
they go to first after a Marvel film and
anyone who says new rockstars I
literally met a guy at Seth Myers just
the other night he was like one of the
producers and he's like I just watched
your film I was like watching the
breakdown of new rockstars and I was
like you watch new rockstars that's
crazy this is like a 60-year-old man um
so just know keep it up like people
people love the content and and it your
comment sections alone are just amazing
it's very very kind of you to say Iman
and and I we really do try here we take
our cues from people like you honestly
and having just very wholesome positive
outlook toward it and yeah and just
having the grace to understand that
sometimes people don't have all the
information and that includes having the
grace to forgive um like Studios for
still trying to figure it out you know
or everyone worked on the Marvels is
like so talented you know and like
there's so many great artists and
musicians and actors and bfx artists and
you know n Casta like all these people
are just like amazing and there's it's a
celebration that this movie came out you
know exactly it's and like just I'm sure
you breaking down the films and like me
working on it it's humanized Marvel so
much more for me like they're not just
like these spontaneous films that just
exist randomly in the theaters like they
take years to make and years to develop
and everyone who works on these movies
or they genuinely love their job like
sure there's hard days and Nia probably
wanted to rip people's heads off at some
point point but she never showed it and
she was always positive and anytime I
wanted to talk about Comics anytime I
wanted to talk about my character she
was always there and attentive and I
just got that energy from everyone so
people care and and they're making the
films and all these shows for nerds so
something to consider that's know yeah
thank you for saying all that um I saw
that you talked to Seth Myers and you
mentioned as part of your research that
you were looking at the '90s X-Men
animated series that you were reading
Jonathan Hickman's new X-Men uh and you
had also SED last time we talked
Jonathan Hickman's time Runs Out
storyline is your favorite or one of
your favorites leading to Secret Wars
and then on weeks after you and I
chatted Kevin feige went up on stage at
Comic Con and announced the secret Wars
film seems like isn't that crazy it's
it's insane it's almost like you knew
something Maybe not maybe maybe um seems
like they're adapting Hickman's
storyline at least from an Outsiders
point of view I assume you're siloed out
of some of those conversations but
hypothetically you know looking at
things happening right now if the you
know the studio order established the
mcu's take on Kang as the equivalent of
molecule man from that storyline that's
what I was trying to tell everyone okay
okay okay this is we're having a real
interview right now this is my we're
just nerding out okay you finish your
thought and then and then I'll I'll tell
you what like my theories are because
I'm I genuinely am not prev to any of
these conversations great so we can just
we could just uh nerd out on this I love
it okay okay great Kang equals molecule
man at least in the way structurally
that story works I I agree I agree he is
like the doomsday device of all these
different realities and then God Emperor
Doom comes in to pick up the pieces and
build battle world out of the Void
that's what I'm that's what I want to
see happen but I'm I'm not in control of
this franchise what version of this are
you most excited to see as a comic
reader and as a fan okay okay so my my
theories because it's like okay the time
runs out and like Secret Wars it's a lot
of characters and a lot of storylines
and I had to reread it twice myself like
just to understand the basis of it so
Translating that into film would be near
impossible I think without it being
super clunky and and then you have so
many new characters and a lot of the new
characters that are being introduced
they don't exactly exist in the comics
or they different versions of them so I
think it would make sense for yes K to
be a version of the molecule man where
he you know like Owen Reese existing in
every single universe and there's
different variants of him we've already
seen that so that makes sense yep but
also I feel like he could be he could be
the molecule man and the beyonder all at
once that actually makes a lot ofense
Beyond if there was a king Prime like or
something that that had the ultimate
power and and you know CU cuz molecule
man absorbs the beyonders powers and
gives it to doom and who gives it to
Reed Richards right so if if you like
cut out a couple middleman and it's just
Kang and then maybe there's a different
version of Kang that like is the main
Miku man that's like helping maybe it's
even like a Victor timley type who's
like kind of more innocent and wants to
help doom and he's the one who absorbs
the other molecule men and the beyonders
powers okay the big Kang or they kill
all the kings and they're they they they
meet their big boss and that's King
prime or something that's that's how I
see it and then the rest of the times
out uh thing can play out the same I
think I love that we have to bookmark
this because last time we were like like
speculating I'm telling two weeks later
they came out and said Secret Wars was
happening so okay when we start maybe
we're manifesting something here right
we're we're willing it into existence
we're dream walking into our alternate
timeline selves to make this happen yeah
entanglement is a big component of what
makes the Marvels fun and you can keep
that fun going by entangling snacking
and surprise with bxu boxu is a premium
Japanese snack box that works with
family businesses all over Japan to
deliver a new theme of authentic jaese
snacks every month and honestly it makes
a great gift fun snacks that you usually
have to travel to try people love it and
Beyond the snacks each boxu comes with a
booklet that teaches you all about the
theme and where the snacks come from so
that you can have a deeper appreciation
for what it is you're munching on the
first box of any boxy subscription is
the seasons of Japan after that you
receive a new theme every month with
curated seasonal snacks one of my
favorite things for these is a white
strawberry it's so sweet and the
strawberries infused with white
chocolate to just make like oh my God
it's Heaven it's a bite of heaven I'm
telling you but they also have these
Smoky radish chips which compared with
the the sweet white chocolate strawberry
this just makes for a nice Smoky
something
something oh yeah oh so good so good
both I and the new Rockstar's office
have been receiving these boxes for ages
we love them so if you want to try boxu
and support the channel click the link
in the description and use code
rockstars to get $15 off your order one
of the things when we last talked was
about the the Bengals which we now know
are quantum band
which is a specific thing for Marvel
Comics did naming them Quantum bands as
far as you know imply any other
historical owners of these like like
quazar and stuff yeah maybe I still
think okay I still think eon's a
contender like I think he definitely for
him I I I know you did you say did you
have a theory about like was it still
Eon or my just explanation of like
canonically Eon created them I my theory
is that they're not going to make Eon at
least right now a physical I don't think
they'll say Eon but I swear there was a
version of our script where darbin
actually Nam drops Eon like this was his
grave or something where they found it
oh so in my head that still makes sense
yeah um but it for me to link everything
together and just condense some of these
Dimensions I feel like the newer
Dimension would be the quantum
zone right like it's made out of energy
why not and and njma also like mentions
how um how her being called a Jin is
like one of many names so I feel like
her saying your dimension is also like
one of many names that we don't know yet
so like Quantum Zone could totally be
one of them um but yeah I don't know
about the different Wares uh the the 10
Rings thing in our show I don't know who
that whose idea that was why I mean
there I'm sure someone is smart in
plotting something to do with shangi but
I I genuinely have no idea yeah we like
in our breakdown we were trying to
figure out like do they much power you
realize what they're doing to you like
they're just setting these things up and
letting you do the work no don't tell me
that please don't let that be the cas
I'm not well I think I should say that I
like the I I might just not be a part of
this
conv but I feel bad now no no I think
there's probably some kind of linkage um
yeah I would love to visit the nor
Dimension I did you see the finale of
Loki by the way I did the fact that the
nor Dimension had a big tree in now just
makes me fascinated for what kind of
connection there could be I don't know
any tree any tree every tree I realized
that's a dumbest thing I think I've ever
said any place there's a tree uh there's
a con it must be connected I mean is
kind of now atlasing everything in the
Marvel Universe it sounds like so
technically he's carrying all of us but
um real quick I want to talk about
aladana and I love the sequence because
if you look at you in every one of these
scenes you were just rocking out and
it's you're just Zemo in the background
of every
um was there more to this sequence I
want to see those memes it's going to be
great I want to ask is there more to
this sequence that we didn't see in the
Final Cut of the movie yeah I hope they
release it on Blu-ray or something yeah
it was we shot it for like a hot minute
and it was we still shot it like at our
back lot so we didn't do like any on
location work except um that grassy
planet where Carol and Monica like have
and they all have that talk of like oh
I'm sorry oh it's my fault Hala dying
that was the only like actual onsite
thing that we did wow okay so I know you
thought otherwise I thought it was
volume shows what I know this is how you
know I'm not a VFX I get it I get it the
like way it's framed can be a little
misleading but it was real uh like
somewhere in the Farmland of
London but um no alad was so fun because
we were still like at the studio but
just on on on the other end and all
these extras were amazing dancers they
had all this makeup
um I couldn't stop staring at people and
they just came with all this energy that
every single take we were doing it was
like they were getting even more hyped I
I could not believe it and and the song
was so good our rehearsals for this were
so fun um yeah so the song is like much
it's a legitimate like three minute song
There's a moment where uh I think Carol
starts singing there there's bits where
Camala is singing like I I I was having
so much fun I'm such a musical theater
nerd so I would I would love to see like
this actually like imagine an Aladin
musical like forget Steve Rogers this is
this is what I want to see um yeah it
was it was very fun and the costumes
were just insane honestly I didn't
realize how crazy it was until like
people online started saying this just
like a weird movie and I was like yeah
but in the best way possible yeah I
thought it was really fun I I could have
seen more of aladana honestly I think it
would have been fun little moment that I
didn't even realize the first time I
watched it when Carol is floating with
the quantum bands in space kamala's big
hand reaches out and Scoops them you're
not wearing the Bangals there so does
that mean it's something with her mutant
abilities that are allowing her to
access that hard light I don't think her
pow has come from the bangal at all like
I think she just wears them as an
accessory now um they I think they just
were the key and and the doors kept open
so she just now has all this access to
the no and her like the way I I
Justified is her mutant power is the
ability to to wield the into shape it
like I I keep going back to comron he
wasn't able to do that like his n came
out spiky and uncontrolled he wasn't a
mutant Cala is and and it's a very
specific power I guess like almost the
technicality but that's that's my head
cannon at least so yes she can use her
powers without the bangal um and then
the Bangals I guess help her access more
of it I love that approach of it I it it
makes a lot of sense to me too and I
have to ask about Samuel L Jackson uh I
love that story that you told us Seth
Myers about how he told you to retake it
because the high five blocked your face
so he's just he's like El me um I had
read recently that Sam Jackson
apparently hates to run and I noticed
there's a shot in the movie where he's
just like sitting in a chair and he
shoots
somebody what was it like shooting with
Samu L Jackson is there any he sits all
the time sit he's always
sitting and if there's no chairs he'll
find one it's amazing um he's he's very
very patient well not like patient with
me he was very gentle and and I think
knew how new I was and and gave me space
to play and try and he's also very
playful and I think what was so
impressive about him is how much he
loved Nick Fury he was the only person
who came off of secret Invasion and onto
our film so he was literally keeping
continuity for his own character which
like I I honestly like I had the same
experience no one from Miss Marvel
except the cons were on the movie so I
got to my first day of stunt training
and everyone's like so what are your
powers what you
yeah right so it's it's tough because
like we're the only ones who are really
transitioning and and it's a completely
different crew so he's very very
professional and very good about like
okay this is what my character needs I
wouldn't say that let's get to the next
take like he's very to the point and I
and I love that because he brings so
much of that to Nick Fury anyway um and
I love how much more playful he was in
this film I think the cons and Cala just
like really bring it out and and the
tone of the film is also so goofy that
he was kind of leaning into it I think
he was so just let's have a good time
we're here with cats and space and and
he's so good with the cat so it was it
was very cool watching him work it felt
like he was kind of back to form um
which was just really fun to see from
him um okay so circling back to the
beginning the MCU notebook you're still
using it Heaven feige hasn't taken it
from you and I read somewhere that you
have not bothered Mr feige about 616
because they Holding Out for Miz Marvel
season 2 do we have any update there
that is the generalization of what I
actually said in the interview I think
um okay no I mean it's true I'm not
taking that seriously anymore I I
because you know what the fans every
time I do an interview and they want to
like bring up the 616 thing everyone
always starts with by the way I think
you're right and I'm like that's
validation enough for me you know I
think maybe when Reed Richards sets the
whole universe back to normal maybe that
could be one
199999 or you know I just
I I see it as a separate Universe I
don't see it as like an adaptation of
the comic so it really depends you know
perspectives right and I think that's a
valid point of view wants to see it his
way I think it's 616 with an asterisk
right now and then once Reed Richards
resets the universe then it is a true
616 once it has X-Men but see how much
like we're having to talk about it and
do you see how much we could have
avoided this if he just like allowed the
fans to keep the name yep it was a
simpler time in mind when we had six
members identifi the MCU now I just have
three y all right we'll leave it there
Iman this has been amazing
congratulations on uh on thank you so
much all the praise you're getting well
earned praise for the Marvels and I
think like this is going the word of
mouth on this movie is going to be great
I think I was just at a screening in San
Francisco on Wednesday and everyone was
feeling great afterwards it was a full
theater you know and I'm like it's a
Wednesday night that's all we can ask
for everyone yeah so just like have a
good time I do have a question for you
though
um okay can you still enjoy films and TV
without getting all analytical or or
like what's the the thing you can watch
without having to break it down in your
head okay yeah so the answer to both
parts of the question is the same I
watch garbage reality TV on the weekends
and at night so it's not garbage I think
it's quality reality TV the challenge
MTV is the challenge and then I watch
MTV wow well we get it on like whatever
uh Paramount plus I think it's one of
these like how do I even find this it's
like that was so unexpected you're like
Escape Disney plus Netflix Paramount
plus I unplug and my it's something my
wife and I are able to bond over so that
and then um and then like Great British
baking show like I need something which
just reality my favorite show ever it's
it's it's good wholesome cont I mean are
you up to date yes I believe they're in
this the quarterfinals now um yeah I
like how they just had dessert week and
it's like aren't all of these desserts
and it was all caramel it was all
caramel which is just mean and no like
caramel buty I like people why is this
so difficult don't you think Paul
designed the technical challenge to be
way too hard like if they all fail then
it's your fault Paul Hollywood yeah he's
like because people have been doing too
well I think in this grou they're very
good they're all really good I was so
sad to see Saku leave I wanted her to
take it all I know I'm rooting for Tasha
this time Tasha's great she's really
good she had like a scary week where I
like oh no she GNA get cut she's great
yeah does Dan remind you of Michael
fosbender at all please tell me yes he
does he does seem a bit like Michael
fastfender yeah yeah I see it is it like
it's the smile okay that's it no my my
my brother didn't see it but I I think
he does look like it this was great this
is great this is the interview so yeah
to answer your question that's how I'm
able to still like uh there's movies and
there's just kind of like whatever
unplugged content and then that kind of
like I need the balance because if it
was just all like franchise nerdom
content all the time I think it it
really would burn me out I got to have
like a mix my diet I can imagine I don't
even understand how you're still going
and with the energy that you're going
with it's it's you are the reason I'm
still going IM you brought so much life
back into the MCU and I'm telling you
Robert Downey Jr got it it felt like him
getting booked on Iron Man was like hey
these things they don't come to
everybody these opportunities so I'm
just G to have fun with this and like if
I had a note and not like anyone's going
to listen to my notes but for All actors
in the MCU just have fun with this enjoy
the ride and you seem to be doing that
so I'm so proud of you and I'm so happy
for you thank you so much that genuinely
means a lot like coming from you I like
remember the Sam Basher days and
everything I was like this crazy this so
weird like you guys have such a large
group of people now and the whole
production like it's amazing
go us seriously than uh congrats enjoy
the rest of your night and enjoy the
rest of this ride it's thank you so
[Music]
much